>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Well, good afternoon
and welcome to the African
and Middle East Division
of the Library of Congress.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb, chief of
the division, and I'm delighted
to see you all here today for
this very special presentation
with Dr. Yoel Finkelman,
the Judaic curator
at the National Library
of Israel in Jerusalem.
As most of you already know,
our division is made
up of three sections.
The African, the Middle East,
and the Hebraic sections.
We're responsible for materials
from 78 different countries
in the Near East, Central
Asia, the Caucuses,
as well as from the entire continent
of Africa, North and Sub-Saharan.
And, we are very active in acquiring
and developing our collections,
briefing our visitors coming from
all the countries of the region,
organizing programs,
symposia, workshops.
We also invite scholars and experts
who have researched and done work
in our areas of responsibility
to share with us their insights
and their findings, so that all
of us attending and participating
in the programs leave
enriched with new information
and a better understanding
of what the cultures
and the societies are about.
We are particularly happy to
welcome Dr. Finkelman today,
because he's a librarian
and shares similar interests
with members of our Hebraic section.
His presentation today,
entitled from "Bomberg
to Beit Midrash" discusses
Hebrew printing in Venice,
a topic that complements one
that was discussed last month
at the Low Library Symposium, and we
have members of the Low Library here
to commemorate 500
years since the founding
of the Jewish ghetto Venice.
But, to tell you more our
very own Sharon Horowitz,
a senior reference librarian here,
in the Hebraic section we introduce
Dr. Finkelman and the program
after which you will be invited
to see a wonderful display
of rare book related
to the presentation.
So, Sharon, and thank you.
>> Thank you Mary Jane,
good afternoon.
On behalf of the Hebraic section
let me add my welcome to you all
to the African and Middle
Eastern Division meeting room.
Thank you for joining us.
As you heard I'm Sharon Horowitz,
a reference librarian
in the Hebraic section.
The Hebraic section marks its
beginnings in 1912, with the receipt
of 10,000 Hebrew books and pamphlets
whose purchase was made possible
by a gift from New York
philanthropist Jacob Schiff.
From those humble beginnings,
our collections have grown
to around 250,000 items in Hebrew,
Yiddish, Ladino, Judeo-Persian,
and other Hebraic script languages,
and also includes an important
collection of books in the languages
of Ethiopia, Amharic to
Grenya Angez [phonetic].
The section's holdings are
particularly strong in the areas
of Bible and rabbinic, Hebrew
language and literature,
responsa and Jewish history.
Two of our missions in this division
are to publicize our collections
and to bring people
into the library.
One way we do that is by holding
lectures and having programs
such as this one that we
are hosting here today.
I'd like to call your attention
to the beautiful display of books
from the Hebraic section,
printed in 16th century Venice.
The display and informative
checklist were prepared
by my colleague Dr. Ann
Brenner [assumed spelling].
Please allot time to look at
these books before you leave.
Each book is numbered, and the
numbers correspond to a number
in the checklist, and so you
can follow along by yourselves
and see these beautiful things.
The number one book is closest to
the entrance of the reading room.
Today we are very fortunate to have
as our speaker Dr. Yoel Finkelman.
Dr. Finkelman is the curator
of the Judaic collection
at the National Library of
Israel where he is responsible
for the acquisition of new and
rare items, digitization projects,
and collection development.
One item of business before
I turn the podium over.
This event is being videotaped
for subsequent broadcasting.
There will be a formal question
and answer period after the lecture
at which the audience is encouraged
to ask questions and give comments.
Please be advised that your
voice and image may be recorded
and later broadcast
as part of this event.
By participating in the question
and answer period you are consenting
to the library's possible
reproduction
and transmission of your remarks.
And, now please join me in
welcoming Dr. Yoel Finkelmann.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Is this clear?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, first, I want to
begin with thanks of my own,
in particular to Dr. Ann Brenner,
who's work in making this
event possible is important.
And, in particular for her work on
the exhibit in the back of the hall.
The Talmud has rather unpleasant
things to say about people who stand
in the presence of their teachers
and issue determinant
conclusions on matters of law.
And, fortunately, our topic is
not actually about matters of law,
otherwise it would be very
uncomfortable speaking
about 16th century Italian-Hebrew
printing in Dr. Brenner's presence,
because I feel like an amateur
in the presence of an expert.
In addition, I wanted
to thank Sharon Horowitz
and Gale Shirazi [assumed spelling]
who really put an enormous amount
of effort to make my visit
here, both for this lecture
and for some professional
meetings, possible.
Finally, I want to say that I
remember visiting the Library
of Congress as a little kid on
a family vacation to Washington,
and coming from a family
of bookworms and --
and nerds it was naturally
on our agenda.
And, speaking here as an adult
in a much more official capacity
is really genuinely an honor.
It's -- it's really
a trip to be here,
if I can be a little less formal.
I want to talk about a topic that's
really very close to my heart
and comes from the fact that deep
down I think I'm basically the
Yeshiva boy and that my attachment
to Jewish texts and my attachment
to rabbinic learning was
founded in the Beit Midrash.
And, like many people who
spent time in the Beit Midrash,
you get used to these big tomes of
the Talmud, of the Shulchan Aruch,
the code of Jewish law, of the tour
and another important
code of Jewish law.
[Inaudible] a Jewish law, and
you can kind of take these things
for granted, and in
practice, if we think --
well, also as a kind of
naïve Yeshiva student,
you take this for granted,
you get used to it.
You also are not aware,
at least I wasn't,
of the way in which the physical
materials, what we might call
in more broad terms the
technology of printing,
affects directly what it is that
students do with one another.
What is the encounter of
the learner, of the student,
of the participant in
this learning process?
What is the encounter of that person
with the text, with the knowledge
that is embodied in that
text, with fellow students?
And, as we'll see later on,
with longer arcs of history
and transnational groups
whose identity
and religious practice
has formed by these texts.
And, as I've gotten older, I've
gotten a little prospective on that,
and I'm hoping that what we can
work on in the next few minutes is
to talk about how early 16th
century, particularly in Venice,
was a major stopping
point for the development
of how rabbinic learning has
happened through the ages.
Not that it doesn't have
a prehistory and not
that there weren't
developments afterwards.
Finally, I should talk about --
mention that I'm talking about a
certain subset of rabbinic texts.
The overwhelming majority of
Hebrew printings do not follow some
of the patterns we're
going to talk about.
But, some of the most critical,
seminal, concrete works
that cemented rabbinic
self-understanding do fit into some
of the patterns we're
going to talk about.
I'm going to start with
something a little bit inter --
actually anachronistic.
And, this was a -- New York's Time
put up a really fascinating article
on -- on noise -- sound and its
relationship to architecture,
and we're going to hope
that this cooperates.
Right now, it's not cooperating.
So, while we're at it
we'll skip over to a video
of a contemporary Beit Midrash.
Do we have any sound here?
Here we go.
Contemporary Beit Midrash,
a small Beit Midrash,
and it is a noisy and loud place.
We don't have to watch the entire
seven minutes of this video.
This is a small suburban environment
-- a small suburban environment,
the North Miami Beach Kollel.
In Florida you get a sense of noise,
books piled up on one another,
people in conversation.
The learning occurs through
this kind of conversation.
Now, if we go back --
let me see if I can get
that New York Times
thing to appear again.
Here we go.
This is a kind of sound
scape of the reading room
in the New York Public Library, and
what the New York Times wants to get
across is that despite the fact
that librarians are famous
for their "Be quiet."
In fact, there's a great deal of
noise, conveniently the cart is
from the Jewish division, so it
ties right into what we're doing.
And, there's actually an
enormous amount of ambient noise
in what is supposed to
be a quiet environment.
These are two entirely different
conceptions of what the look
and feel of a study hall
is supposed to be like.
In the New York Times case,
silence is punctuated by noise
that you would hardly notice,
unless you were sensitive to it,
which the New York Times article
gives us the ability to do.
And, the Beit Midrash -- and
this is a small Beit Midrash.
If you go into the Beit Midrash,
let's say in the Near Yeshiva Shiva
in Jerusalem or the Lakewood
Yeshiva in New Jersey,
probably the two largest
Yeshiva's in the world today.
The Lakewood Yeshiva at the moment
has between 7000 and 8000 students,
the size of a small university and
probably has more students than were
in Eastern European yeshivas in all
of Eastern Europe at
any given moment.
You just -- it's just
cacophony it's just noise,
and without being overtly
anachronistic,
although just being a little bit
anachronistic, I want to claim
that this is linked to some of
the decisions that were made
in the 16th century in terms
of printing of rabbinic texts.
I've shown these pictures.
Most of the items that we're going
to talk about are going to come
from the collection of
the National Library.
We don't have a great collection
of glossed Christian sources.
So, these are kind of -- had I
been a little more put together I
could've taken them from the
Library of Congress collection,
but these are basically
items that I've kind
of picked up from the internet.
These are early glossed
Christian Bibles and manuscript
in early printing, and
if you would show this
to any traditional yeshiva
boy, the first they'd say is,
"Why is there a page of Talmud
written in Latin characters?"
And, in fact, this is kind of the
core of what I want to try to talk
about is this notion of a central
text in the middle surrounded
by apparatus or surrounded
by commentary
or what has become more
popular term is peritext.
But, I don't like peritext
in this context as a term,
because sometimes it's
really difficult to figure
out what's the text and
what's the peritext,
what's central and what's not.
And, in fact, this has become --
what's unique in these rabbinic
printings is not necessarily the
layout per se.
What's unique is that this layout
became central and was maintained
for centuries well after these
kinds of glossed Christian bibles
and polyglot bibles and
works of canon law kind
of dropped out of fashion.
A lawyer friend of mine, when
I was discussing this with him,
told me that there are some basic
works of contemporary law that work
with similar kinds of apparatuses
-- apparati [phonetic] in --
in law school, but he
didn't send me any example,
so I don't have them here.
Now, in fact, if we start
looking at the Jewish sources
where I feel much more comfortable
talking, the kind of standard form
in manuscript versions, even
of glosses, of commentaries,
is going to be in manuscript form --
a manuscript of the
commentary itself.
Let me take a step back and -- and
introduce what we're talking about.
In traditional rabbinic
study, whether we're talking
about the Bible or whether
we're talking about the Talmud
or whether we're talking about
codes, you have a central text.
The text is canonical.
It's canonical not only in
the sense that it is part
of this larger collection of
works that are deemed holy,
but it is canonical
in that it had --
has a particular sacred status that
can often be defined in very clear
and unambiguous, sometimes
legal terms.
So, the Bible is authoritative
in the Jewish tradition
as the literal word of
god, and while, in fact,
Jewish practices often quite removed
from what the bible describes based
on layers and layers of
rabbinic interpretation,
its status as canonical is
defined as the almost --
the constitutional -- as the deepest
layer of the authoritative text.
The Talmud is -- even the
Talmud itself is layered.
The previous early stratum called
the Mishnah and the later stratum,
also in two versions the Jerusalem
Talmud and the Babylonian Talmud,
which is itself a commentary
on the Mishnah.
But, both of these have
very formal status.
The Mishnah, is authoritative.
The later Rabbis --
the Rabbis identified
as Amu Raheem [phonetic] the authors
of the later Talmud, Babylonian
and Palestinian Talmud,
do not as a matter
of formal rule argue
with the Mishnah.
They interpret the Mishnah.
They often interpret the
Mishnah so creatively as to be
in practice legislating anew,
but formally a leader authority does
not argue with an earlier authority.
After the closing of the
Babylonian Talmud, for all intents
and purposes later authorities
do not argue with the Talmud.
They interpret the Talmud,
and they interpret the Talmud,
and therefore determine
matters of law.
At some point, we'll talk a
little bit later about this,
[inaudible] which he quite
explicitly states he wants
to be the final word -- he wants
this to be the authoritative voice
of what everybody has to follow.
And, the collective Jewish
community with the exception
of a certain subgroup
of the Ammonite Jewish community
essentially ignores him,
while the Shulchan Aruch, the
16th century code of Jewish law,
gains for itself this status
-- formal status of authority.
Now, what happens with these works
of canon is naturally
they are ambiguous,
because all texts are ambiguous,
but in particular the Talmud --
the Bible is ambiguous,
because isn't terribly concise.
And, the Talmud is ambiguous,
because it telegraphs all kinds
of information and is virtually
incomprehensible on its own
without some kind of commentary.
And, later codes by virtue of
shrinking much larger material --
much more expansive material
into a bottom line leave
out all kinds of details.
So, here we have ambiguous texts
that are formerly authoritative
and part of the canon, and
they give rise to commentary.
Now, what do you do
with these commentaries?
How do you visualize them?
How does the student see them?
How do you lay them out on the page?
How do you present
them to the student?
Now, like all printing
endeavors it's some combination
of finances, technology,
and culture.
How much can we afford?
What are we capable to do?
What does the technology enable
us to do, and culturally,
what matters to us, and
how does it matter to us?
Chicken and egg problems here
are going to become complicated,
but let's look at this,
essentially a random example.
Fifteenth century Italian manuscript
of [inaudible] the Pentateuch,
Rashi [assumed spelling] the most
important mediaeval commentator,
probably the most important
Jewish commentator ever --
his commentary both on the Bible
and on the Talmud are
absolutely indispensable.
And, for all intents and purposes,
certainly in the case of the Talmud,
less so in the case of the Bible,
but for all intents and purposes,
if the Talmud is ever printed,
it is certainly printed
with Rashi's commentary.
If the Bible is printed, it is also.
If it's printed with
any apparatus at all,
it's with Rashi's commentary,
but here we have simply
Rashi's commentary
without the text upon
which it is commenting.
Why? Because, manuscripts are too
expensive to waste time and space
on anything else, and a patron
who is ordering a manuscript copy
of Rashi's commentary on something
presumably already owns a --
a copy of the text upon
which Rashi is commenting.
Or, at the very least knows
that text by heart or assumes
that the scholar is going
to know that text by heart.
So, let's save a lot of
money and a lot of resources
by simply treating the commentary
as if it is a separate volume.
But, of course, Rashi's commentary
on the bible cannot be
read cover to cover.
It can't be done, because it's
really a series of short paragraphs
that are comments on a particular
word or a particular biblical verse,
and there is no obvious connection
between one line and the other.
It can only be read as a line
by line commentary on the Bible.
And, therefore, this book on
its own is virtually useless
without either knowing
the biblical text by heart
or having a manuscript copy of it.
Even more dramatically is
Rashi's commentary on the Talmud.
Here, also a 15th century
manuscript.
Rashi's commentary
after its publication
or after its appearance became
absolutely indispensable.
And -- and [inaudible] has
argued completely convincingly
that Rashi's commentary
made it possible for people
to study Talmud independently
by filling in all kinds of gaps
and understanding what's going on.
Here, too, we have
simply the commentary.
It is useless without the Talmud,
but the Talmud is not
presented here.
Again, let's save some money.
If we move to the incunable period,
here we have psalms with Radak,
Rabbi David Kimchi's commentary,
an extremely important
commentary here from 1477.
And, here we get to
play a little bit.
Notice the page layout.
We have the text of the Psalms
themselves in block square letters,
and we have the commentary in,
what we would call
today, a different font.
What's the text and what's
the power text, right?
The Psalms here are not the text.
The text is Kimchi's commentary, and
the psalms are there to enable you
to study Kimhi's commentary,
because this is a lousy way
to present the text of the psalms
themselves, because if I wanted
to recite psalms as a ritual
kind of prayer or if I wanted
to study psalms as part of biblical
poetry, this is a terrible way
to do it, because one psalm
of seven or eight verses
or 15 verses is going to be
laid out on three or four pages.
And, I have to skip
stuff in the middle
to read the text of the psalm.
The -- the text of the
verse is there to enable me
to study the commentary of Kimchi.
Now, we move forward to
something that starts
to look a little bit
more like the page layout
of a standard Talmudic text today.
Here, a Spanish -- Pentateuch --
commentaries of Rashi and the
ancient Aramaic translation
of Onkelos beginning
to lay out in columns.
Looks a little bit more like
a polyglot Bible as well,
with the text of the
Bible in the middle
with -- with the vowel markings.
And, here, we start to see
a more interesting interplay
between the texts that are laid out.
So, that's a kind of transition.
Now, we move forward into
Venice in the sixteenth century,
and we start to see things
that are more complicated.
Now, part of what's going on here,
as we start to see these kinds
of texts, is that printing
enables lowering of prices.
Printing enables much
more of an ability to plan
in advance how you want to lay out
these texts, so that you can fit
on a page something
quite this complicated.
There were attempts to do
things like this in manuscript,
but they weren't able to include
quite as much as what's going
to be included here, and you
have a market that is interested.
Here, we're looking at the
second edition of Bomberg's --
Daniel Bomberg's "Mikraot
Gedolot" a rabbinic Bible.
Certainly will be celebrating
next year the --
the 500th anniversary of the
first rabbinic Bible in 1517,
and a copy of the first rabbinic
Bible, the first Mikraot Gedolot is
in the exhibit space in the back.
And, it's in the top five of the
most important printing events
in the history of the Hebrew book.
We're using the second edition,
because the second edition is the
one focused more on Jewish readers
than the first edition,
which was more focused --
again, this is a matter of
degree, not a matter of kind,
but more focused on
Christian readership.
And, here what we have -- I don't
know, can you see my -- the arrow?
Okay, we have the text of the Bible.
We have the Aramaic --
ancient Aramaic translation,
the commentary of Rashi,
indispensable.
The commentary of the Spanish
mediaeval exergy Eben Ezra,
and as well the Masoretic notes.
The Masoretic notes which had
outside of a small circle of kind
of OCD people who were really
concerned with the exact spelling
of every last word in
the Masoretic edition
of the bible had largely
fallen into day
to day disuse by a typical reader.
But, in the Mikraot Gedolot
in Bomberg's rabbinic bible
they were absolutely critical,
because one of the most important
influences of this publication is
that it really set the fixed
Masoretic text from then on.
But, I'm less interested in
the history of the text --
the Masoretic text of the bible
itself and more interested
in what we've got going on here,
which is a primary text laid
out in the middle, multiple
commentaries laid out around,
and what is also going to become
critical -- we'll see more examples.
The commentaries are
aware of each other.
That is to say Rashi on this side
of the page comments on the Bible.
Eben Ezra comments on the Bible,
but also explicitly makes reference
to Rashi's previous commentary.
So, we have on the
page a conversation,
a three-way conversation
that's going on.
Another example -- we can kind
of multiply these examples,
and we see the way -- Alfasi,
the great north African -- the --
who's -- who's [inaudible] --
who's work kind of summarizing
and condensing the Talmud
into its bottom line,
was often studied as the primary.
There was a while when people were
not quite sure whether the Talmud
was going to become the most
important Jewish rabbinic text
or Alfasi's was going to
become the major core of study.
And, here, too, we get -- we get
the central text in the middle,
[inaudible] Eben Habib commentary
on Alfasi, also from Bomberg.
Now, we're going to talk a little
bit about Talmud, because Talmud is
in many ways the core -- observant
Jews today are certainly much more
Jews of the Talmud than
they are of the Bible.
So, here we have a
1482 incunable edition
from Spain, [inaudible] Kiddushin.
Nope -- spelling error there.
It should say Kiddushin,
not Kiddush.
And, here, again, you see this
kind of multiple text on the page.
It's clear that the
Talmud is the core text.
Rashi's commentary on the outside,
but the standard page of Talmud,
which we'll get to later
on, had not yet formed.
But, as we move forward,
some [inaudible] Talmud,
we also have a volume
of that in the exhibit.
Fifteen -- this is a 1510 edition.
He begins including not only the
Talmud in the middle of the page,
but Rashi and the commentary
of the Tosephists,
the Ashkenazi commentaries
on the Talmud.
Now, let's just skip ahead
to one more page before we talk
a little bit about what's going
on here in these Talmuds.
Another typo, it should say 1520.
This is a Bomberg edition.
Bomberg -- Daniel Bomberg,
the printer --
Venice printer is particularly
important,
probably the most important
printing of the Talmud
because he was the first to
print the complete edition
of the Babylonian Talmud.
And, in addition to
that, he also made --
well, he did two things that
became absolutely critical
in the future of the Talmud.
The first is that he
paginated all the pages.
Not simply paginated them
for his particular edition,
but he was very conscious
about setting a fixed
pagination for the entire Talmud.
Only he could do it
because he's the first one
to ever print the entire thing.
And, he was conscious of this,
and instead of simply being able
to reference a page of
Talmud, the third chapter of --
of [inaudible] Kiddushin,
he would be able
to identify a much
smaller body of text.
And, you could enable cross
referencing much more easily.
He was very conscious of this,
and in fact, in further printings
of commentaries and codes he
would insert page numbers,
references to his own edition of the
Talmud, creating a kind of monopoly.
It's like, you know, buying Windows
and getting it packaged with --
with Internet Explorer, except
-- this little bit, I guess,
also anachronistic now, that
unlike your web browser,
you can pick whatever
web browser you want.
But, he essentially was able
to create a kind of dependence
on his edition of the Talmud
by printing later editions
with references to his own edition.
So -- so that was one
thing that he did.
The other thing that he did was
that he chose a particular edition
of the commentary of the
Tosephists to put together
with the commentary of Rashi.
And, he had to edit a little
bit, and he had to cut things
down to get it to fit on the page.
And, whether he made a good
decision about which manuscript
of the Tosephists to use
is a matter of some debate.
But, it hardly mattered because
once he included that edition
of the Tosephists commentary on
the page it became the edition
of the Tosephists commentary.
Now, we can start talking a little
bit about the content and talk
about what's going on in
his choice of commentaries.
First of all, Rashi and the
Tosephists, despite the fact
that they're both Ashkenazi, they're
both French-German world of thought
as opposed to the Spanish
and north African traditions
of interpretation, they actually in
kind represent polar extremes of how
to go about commenting
on the Talmud.
The Talmud is a complicated,
dense, obtuse, telegraphic text.
It is virtually incomprehensible,
certainly today,
without the commentary of Rashi,
who fills in gaps, explains what --
questions what cryptic lines means,
fills in background
information, and the like.
His goal is simply to
enable you to read the page.
Well, simply -- that's not really
fair because he was such a master
of commentary that in the
process of teaching you how
to simply read the page and
make sense of the conversation,
he's actually solving all kinds of
problems you weren't even aware of.
And, one of the things that
good rabbinic scholars have
to train themselves to do is to then
go back to the text of the Talmud
and pretend they hadn't read Rashi,
because how would another
commentary read this
without already having superimposed
upon me Rashi's assumptions.
Now, the Tosephists
are worlds apart.
They did something remarkable,
and they said the Mishnah,
the earlier stratum of the Talmud,
is a fairly straightforward text.
The Talmud comes along and
complicates it by assuming, rightly
or wrongly, that the Mishnah
is a coherent and unified text
that doesn't contradict itself.
And, the Talmud comes
along and says --
a later stratum and says the
earlier stratum of the Mishnah --
let's search -- hunt high and
low for contradictions and try
to solve those contradictions.
The Tosephists do the
same thing to the Talmud.
They assume that the Talmud itself,
and here at least historically
speaking,
they're almost certainly
wrong, the Tosephists assume,
let's do to the Talmud what
the Talmud did to the Mishnah.
Let's assume that the
Talmud itself --
the Babylonian Talmud is
itself incoherent text devoid
of any contradictions.
Let's look high and low for
any imaginable contradiction
between any passage in the
Talmud and do all kinds
of creative interpretation
to solve that.
The result is a reworking
of the Talmud,
sometimes a reinterpretation,
sometimes an interpretation
that is radically different than
what appears to be on the page.
The rule appears to
apply across the board.
This is the law.
It turns out it's only on
Tuesday afternoon double headers
with a lefty pitcher.
Those are the kinds of things
that the Tosephists will do.
And, so what you get on the
page are not only the text
of the Talmud itself, the simple
straightforward commentary of Rashi,
but the Tosephists that open up this
world of analysis and hyperlink --
I'm not the first one to notice
this parallel -- the hyperlink --
the Talmud to itself
and create this dialog.
Now, so look what happens
in kind of an image
on the page is we get the
Talmud, which itself branches out
and create conversations
of the two commentators.
And, again we get to two
commentators talking,
not quite with each other,
because the standard opening line
of a paragraph of commentary
by the Tosephists is
perush akuntras [phonetic],
which to oversimplify a little bit,
means this is Rashi's interpretation
of the Talmudic passage,
that is inevitably followed
up with vikasha [phonetic].
That's a problem.
It doesn't work, because if
you interpret this passage
in the Talmud the way
Rashi wants you to,
you're going to create a
contradiction with another passage
in an entirely different volume
that you didn't even remember.
Now, that's remarkable, probably
Rashi would have said in response.
I'm not trying to solve
a problem over there.
I'm just trying to tell you
how to read the page over here
in the simplest possible way.
Again, this is setting it
up a little bit more
dichotomous than it actually is.
But, you create this three-way
conversation on the page.
Let's stop for second and
think about the experience
of the student who
opens up this page.
What are -- we're going to put
on our teacher hats for a second.
And, I'll skip ahead a little
bit to a contemporary work
of academic scholarship,
but let's make explicit --
the implicit assumptions
that are here on the page.
The first is, that
there is a central text.
The central text is the text of
the Talmud with the earlier stratum
of the Mishnah and the later
strata of the Talmud itself.
That text is authoritative.
It is in the center.
It gets the nice woodcut
letters at the top.
We're not exclusively
for holy texts,
but they certainly give it
a certain kind of weight.
That text is central
and authoritative.
Secondly, that text
is not transparent.
You have to do some
work to understand it.
But, the work that you have to do to
understand it is going to be colored
by equally canonical commentaries.
You are not alone in this endeavor
of interpreting the Talmud.
You are working within an
established canon of commentaries.
Third, the commentaries themselves
are in conversation with one other.
They are explicitly in
conversation with one another.
They are creating this
larger conversation.
And, fourth, it is the job of
the student sitting with the book
to put all of this together.
That, I think, is the single most
important educational philosophy
implication of this
type of page layout.
It is -- is this my next slide?
It's not. But, let me go
ahead of myself a second.
Here, is where Torskey's [assumed
spelling] introduction to the Code
of Maimonides [phonetic],
shows in largely random
because the previous slide,
which we haven't gotten
to yet, is of Maimonides Code.
What is his assumption?
I mean, it doesn't have
to be Professor Torskey.
It could be any other work
of contemporary academic scholarship
laid out with the text on the top
and footnotes are peritext
on the bottom.
The assumption is that there is
this older canon of literature,
that the Code of Maimonides
is a text worth understanding,
but that it is the
task of the scholar
to do the interpretive work for you.
Now, granted, he is not
an absolute authority,
despite what many professors
sometimes think.
He has a responsibility to you as
the reader to give you the footnotes
in the apparatus so that you can
go back to the original sources
and double check and see if you
find his interpretation compelling.
But, ultimately, he is
doing the synthesis.
It is the job of the author
of the academic monograph
to do the synthesis for you, as
opposed to, if we go back previously
to our page here where the
assumption is that it is the job
of the student to do the
interpretive work him,
or increasingly, herself.
Now, what happens in the just --
Justinian Talmud is in
addition to the Talmud, Rashi,
and the Tosephists, we
get two other tools.
We get a set of explicit
hyperlinks of explicit footnotes
that cross reference to the
Talmud to a set of other works.
First of all, it cross
references the Talmud to itself.
Sometimes the Talmud has
passages that appear more or less
in identical, or at the
very least similar versions,
in several different places.
So, if you're learning
the passage here,
if you're studying the passage
here, you want to know how
that same passage appears,
if it's in the same text
or what context it's embedded
in in another track date.
It cross references the Talmud
to the Biblical verses so that
if you're studying and
there's a reference to a verse,
you can go back to the
original verse and look it up.
And, finally and most importantly,
and these are the two arrows
that are headed out,
the amishbat [phonetic],
which cross references the
Talmud to codes of Jewish law,
particularly for our
purposes, Maimonides Code
and the Tor [inaudible] Ruch,
the two other major code --
well, the two other -- there's
also [inaudible], the large book
of commandments, which
due to various reasons
of intellectual history
doesn't maintain its same status
over the course of the
-- of the centuries.
And, then you not only have this
kind of triangle of primary text,
commentaries, and conversation
with other -- in --
in conversation with the student.
You have all of that in conversation
with several other volumes,
all of which can be laid out
in an almost identical fashion.
And, then the whole thing
becomes incestuous and impossible,
especially since you might have
a reference to Maimonides Code,
and you might have a reference
to Joseph Karo's [assumed
spelling] Shulchan Aruch.
And, lo and behold, at least in
later editions of Maimonides Code,
who is one of the major
commentators on Maimonides Code,
the same Joseph Karo who
authored the Shulchan Aruch.
In other words, the thing
explodes exponentially.
You don't have a linear
growth in the amount
of possible commentaries
and super-commentaries.
You have an exponential growth, and
you have this kind of intricate web
of possible connections
between different volumes,
each of which has its own
intricate rabbinic page layout.
Just for the sake of the
curiosity, 1616 crack out edition
of the Talmud reappears with
only the Talmud and Rashi,
but that is the exception
that proves the rule.
Since Bomberg, every single
edition with -- I know of three.
No, I know of two exceptions.
Every single edition --
printed edition of the
Talmud afterwards builds
on Bombergs adds perhaps.
But, basically uses Bombergs
format and page layout.
Similar kind of thing going on
in the two infamous editions
of Maimonides Mishnah Torah,
Maimonides Code of Law from 1551.
Justinian and Bragadeen
[assumed spelling].
Not only are these
extremely beautiful volumes,
at least from my personal
subjective perspective.
I think the Justinian Maimonides
Mishnah Torah is perhaps the
beautiful Hebrew printed book ever.
But, that's just my personal
subjective reaction to it.
And, the absolute tragedy
that was created
by these two competing
simultaneous Venice editions
of the Mishnah Torah --
basically the chief rabbi
of Paduah [phonetic] had written
a commentary on Maimonides Code
and wanted to get it published.
Justinian refused.
Bragadeen agreed.
It was one of the first publications
that his publishing house published.
When Justinian heard that there
was a competer opening up,
he quickly grabbed
parts of that commentary
and quickly issued his own version.
This got [inaudible] and
Bogen [assumed spelling]
of Paduah very upset.
He created a hullabaloo [phonetic],
turned to Rabbi Moses Isserles
of Crackow, the most important
rabbinic decider of the day,
and said, "You have to issue a --
a decree that nobody can buy
the new competing edition,"
which Rabbi Isserles did.
And, the two Christian printers
eventually turned to the Pope
and said, "You figure this out."
And, he said, "Well, let's
take a look at what's written
in all this rabbinic stuff."
And, that eventually led to
the burning of the Talmud
and other important
rabbinic books in 1553.
So, you have a kind of sharp
contrast between the beauty
of these printed volumes
and the tragedy
that ensued as a result of them.
But, also you see the
same kind of page layout,
in some ways even more
elaborate, as well as some
of the interpretive hyperlink
apparatus along the commentaries.
Just, you know, the -- the
two other major editions,
which I don't really have time to go
through the whole history
of their printing.
But, the Fortureem [phonetic] and
the Shulchan Aruch, two major codes
of Jewish law that were originally
printed also in a single text
in one volume, gradually developed
much more elaborate apparatuses.
As well, here we have two editions
before kind of the transition
between just the text of the core
and the surrounding commentary.
So, we talk a little bit about how
the educational philosophy of --
of contemporary academic
scholarship is somewhat different.
I want to talk about two
other interesting things
that are going on here.
The first is that another
thing that the Bomberg edition
of the Talmud did was to include,
in addition to the page itself,
several commentaries printed
independently in the back.
He included Maimonides
Commentary of the Mishnah.
He included the commentary
of the Rush Rabino Asher
[phonetic], the Spanish commentator.
And, so he's kind of expanding --
it may not be on the page itself,
but they're still there
in the volume.
But, I want to point to
one thing in his inclusion
of Maimonides Commentary
of the Mishnah,
that involved not publishing
Maimonides Commentary
of the Mishnah.
But, by publishing a translation
into Hebrew of Maimonides Commentary
of the Mishnah, which was originally
published in Judeo -- or --
printed in a -- appeared in
manuscript in Judeo-Arabic,
which was the vernacular at the
time that Maimonides was writing,
or the place -- time and place
that Maimonides was writing.
So, some of this just kind
of create this dialog,
to create this conversation
on the page
and in the volume and
with the students.
Part of that involves reworking --
doing some work with the original
texts in order to enable them
to be part of this conversation,
because in Venice there were --
or the publications were not meant
for sale exclusively in Venice.
Far from it.
But, the European student --
rabbinic student was no
longer fluent in Judeo-Arabic,
and needed this edition in Hebrew in
order to bring Maimonides Commentary
on the Mishnah into
the conversation.
And, what is perhaps even more
interesting if we go backwards
to the Mishnah Torah
is that this layout
of the Mishnah Torah is
explicitly and unquestionably
in absolute violation of
the author's intention.
Maimonides said explicitly in
his introduction to the code,
"I want this to be the final word.
People waste an enormous
amount of time
with this convoluted
text called the Talmud."
There is something enormously
subversive and pretty arrogant
about what Maimonides
thought he was doing.
But, given his conception of
how information is organized,
and the Talmud's conception of
how information is organized --
the Talmud, information is chaotic.
It -- it's created in conversation.
It's like having an argument over
Thanksgiving dinner about politics.
Beside that being a terrible idea
and studying the Talmud
is a good idea.
But -- but the -- the --
you start on one thing,
and you think you're talking
about this that and the other.
And, then it turns out you're
talking about something else,
because somebody --
you said, you know,
how much you appreciate
this candidate.
And, somebody said that
makes you an idiot.
And, then you're talking about gun
control, and then you're talking
about the economy, and then
you're talking about whatever.
And -- and that's how the
Talmud organizes information.
And, Maimonides organizes
information systematically.
Point one, point two, point
three, definition of terms,
implications of those
definitions of terms.
And, Maimonides was
trying to undercut.
And, who wins in these editions?
In these editions that
we're looking at,
these 16th century
edition, the Talmud wins.
I mean, Maimonides wins also,
because he becomes
part of the canon.
But, his core conception of how
information is to be transmitted
and discussed and organizes
loses in the face of the Talmud.
The Talmud emerges victorious.
It's not organized.
It's too complicated
to be organized.
You can only understand this text
and this idea and this definition
of a term by echoing out all the
other definitions and bringing
in another text that's
tangentially related.
And, you have to bring in all these
other people and make a big mess.
It's explicitly against -- and
the -- against Maimonides wishes,
and what these printers are doing
is forcing Maimonides to become part
of the Talmudic tradition
of how interpretation
and in how conversation
and how study occurs.
I also want to look --
this is a lousy picture.
And, we can go off on kind of
the history of printing any
of these books and see how
this page layout plays out.
This is a 20th century
edition of the Mikraot Gedolot
of the rabbinic Bible, published
by Mossad Harafkok [phonetic].
The semi-academic printing
house in Jerusalem and the --
it's a lousy picture, but you have
the text of the Bible over here,
the text of the [inaudible]
translation into Aramaic,
which very few people
understand today.
The text, various medieval
commentaries.
We could talk a lot about
which commentaries get in
and which commentaries get out.
For the 20th century,
late-20th century reader,
mystical interpretations are out.
Shot-oriented, simple reading
interpretations are in.
But, we also get -- you can barely
see them here on this bad --
but some of the academic
apparatus at the bottom.
They want to make sure they have
good manuscript -- I mean, every --
history of printing, they
also cared a great deal
about getting good manuscripts.
But, here there's going
to be footnotes,
there's going to be
explicit conversation
about which manuscripts they used,
what the proper reading
is, and the like.
So, you end up getting --
this tradition carries over
into the 20th and 21st century.
We could talk about --
I'm running way over time.
So, look what ends up happening.
Two more final points.
What you get is on a single
volume, blue are the time periods
of the people on the
page of the Talmud,
the Mishnah in the third
century, the second of 200,
and the Jerusalem Talmud,
the Babylonian Talmud,
Rashi's commentary over
the course of history.
The history -- the conversation
is not only happening on the page,
it's happening across time.
And, if you add the red boxes,
are the people to whom --
the books to whom -- which are
referenced by the Amishbat,
by the other -- by the hyperlinks,
by the footnotes in the margins.
So, you end up getting
across time conversation.
And, you also end up getting
a transnational conversation
because you can map where
are these people are from.
And, where they're writing, and
you end up having a conversation
between numerous people who
are either present on the text
or immediately referenced
to -- to the text.
So, I'm over time but I
want to summarize by saying,
if we go back to our original video.
The Beit Midrash is populated
by people in conversation, loud.
And, part of that is this
notion of dialogic reading
in which the student is
responsible for putting together,
making synthesis out of this
chaotic conversation that is
across generations
and transnational.
And, 16th century Venice
is a central location
for the creation of that.
Chicken and egg questions,
did the print create this?
Yeah, sometimes Bomberg's choice of
this edition of the Tosephists made
that the authoritative
edition of the Tosephists.
But, he couldn't have published an
edition of the Talmud without Rashi,
because that was already
established as the text.
So, chicken and egg
questions are interesting.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
We have about three
minutes for questions.
Yeah, go ahead.
>> Thank you very much.
I sort of walked in to [inaudible].
It's like [inaudible].
>> Yes. Correct.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, correct.
There's this whole-- .
>> -- [Inaudible] and
the remarkable fact
that so many of them
are [inaudible].
Do you have any sense of
where that knowledge comes
from and how that happened?
>> Other than -- I don't want
to say anything absolute,
but the Christian printer, Bomberg,
who hires and works with Jews
or converts to Christianity who were
Jewish and were rabbinic scholars,
or in the course of their work
converted to Christianity.
Since some of this is in the
air, some of it is, you know,
the fact that Venice is
such a central location
for the transmission of -- of --
of goods, but therefore
also information.
And, he hired people who
really cared about this stuff.
It was really a very
small group of people.
>> Where did they [inaudible]?
How did [inaudible]
who'd know [inaudible]?
>> Well, the Ashkenazi
Jewish culture
in the early Middle Ages per capita
was the most prolific rabbinic --
I mean, they were tiny
Jewish communities
that produced per capita enormous
amounts of rabbinic scholarship.
So, that -- then that
begs the question, but-- .
-- Yeah?
>> Thank you very much.
I -- I wanted to ask you a
question on two of the pictures
that show [inaudible] Aramaic text.
What is the relevance
of this Aramaic text?
Why is it [inaudible]?
>> Okay, the Aramaic
commentary, the --
or the translation of [inaudible]
is an ancient Aramaic commentary
that was written and came into use
when Aramaic was the vernacular.
It already in the Talmud
it's referred
to as having a certain
canonical status.
And, the -- there is even
a law that requires --
a law that is largely
kept in the breach,
of reading every week a portion
of the Bible twice and once
that particular translation.
It's a really great way of learning
Aramaic if you don't know Aramaic,
to study the Bible that way.
But, it largely feel into disuse
once Aramaic fell into disuse,
but it was -- it was
part of the canon.
And, it's also in interesting
interpretation.
It's a trans -- it's -- it's
an important stage and move
in rabbinic Judaism away
from strict anthropomorphism.
The Bible the is very
anthropomorphic
and this translation tries to
limit the anthropomorphism.
But, it's part of the canon.
It's almost as if-- .
>> -- It's only [inaudible].
>> It's not -- I mean, every
translation is a commentary,
but it doesn't include
overt, extra commentary.
Yeah?
>> The [inaudible] to hire
experts, he has to know who is
that [inaudible] Bomberg
to manage it.
He has to know how to make decisions
and [inaudible] Bomberg
is a Christian,
and I would assume
he's not [inaudible].
How does he manage?
>> He -- he's not a Talmudic
scholar, but he is a humanist.
And, Renaissance Italy is a place
where, I mean, the first edition
of the rabbinic Bible is -- is --
is much, again, it's
not a matter of kind.
It's a matter of degree.
But, as -- is -- is with
a very Christian spin.
It's meant to appeal
to Christian readers.
And, there is a group of --
increasingly growing group of
Christian people who read Hebrew
or are interested in the Talmud
who have certain basic knowledge.
I don't know what Daniel Bomberg's
own level of Hebrew reading
and -- somebody else knows.
>> He's supposed to be [inaudible].
>> Yeah.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Okay, so -- so, you know,
he knew enough to know
who to talk to, and he cared a lot.
I mean, he was a business man.
He wanted to make money.
But, he understood that -- that
you have to create a good product
for a knowledgeable audience.
You know, he wanted to brand himself
as the Harvard University Press
and not as, you know,
the fly by night Amazon,
you know, print on demand.
And, he was a good business man.
He -- he knew what he -- how
he wanted to brand himself.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, thank you very, very much.
>> You're welcome.
Thank you all.
>> I really appreciate it.
And, again, please do take a look at
the exhibit which Dr. Brenner has --
has put together, because it's
a really fantastic overview --
get a real sense of what
16th century Hebrew printing
in Venice looked like.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.